[Applause]
farther wave might be with the one and
his son
look how far away his hand is when he
catches it but again that length just
astounds us with his agility and I still
it's um three assists as well
[Applause]
where's English using the glass and
thanks at all
those days with 10 oz elusive off the
dribble
Sabonis killing them in the Pete's
policy block by porzingis picked up by
Jack Stephenson Stephenson still pacer
ball porzingis got a piece of it his
second block of the game
[Applause]
stepping on his mod on up against his
hometown cheat porzingis look sit on the
floor drafts across the top shot driving
shooting stops it's a 10-point game he
know very adept with the bounce pass
this that was good past the cave feet
watch KP right there ten feet away the
dotted line will not be the latina finds
porzingis again Shaq's got everyone tuck
the contacts to put it down
and a chance for a three-point plus
series but in vain in pain as KP he will
not be the NAIC light ears you talked
about this earlier one of the keys from
the ship's have not consistently been
able to do anything to slow down the
pace or offense this is peach dkp he has
the hot hand puts up a three
punch the name fifteen straight points
for porzingis and it's a ten point game
the crowd back into his faces theme
tight now that's the loosey-goosey
Joseph drives block by porzingis his
fifth projection of the game broken eye
on the defense again with the rejection
a moments ago at a huge three-pointer
finds porzingis porzingis shot he does
it again but a chance for a three-point
play anyway she's back KP fills the
power line
nothing but net
[Applause]